um for people who don't know St Louis
because when I went there it was green
it felt like Real historic like it felt
like uh it just I never seen nothing
like St Louis it was pretty bruh it's a
real pretty city bro but it's also I was
gonna say it's also like tops the list
all the time of like some of the
deadliest cities in America yeah it was
definitely a place that like I think
probably gets overlooked nationally in
terms of like just the scene and just
kind of what's going on there like um
what would you for you like being like
on the Forefront of the new St Louis I
guess who who some of the artists some
of the uh groups whoever that you you uh
you know are taking note to that are
from out there man for us I lose
uh I personally work with a few people
uh one of my homies my boy Jake baby to
Grady he hard my boy Barry of course I
always
um this is [ __ ] night and Jordan Ward
he's super tight he from St Louis he's
saying though he do a little different
[ __ ] I'm real tapped in with like uh
like the side of St Louis that you
probably wouldn't expect to be there you
feel me which brought me you know what
I'm saying about but um
I don't know bro it's a hoe it's just so
much [ __ ] going on in the loot right now
bro like literally I went I was just
down in St Louis for a week you feel me
for the first time in a minute like I
ain't been able to go home for a minute
you feel me but I was just down there
for a week for a while and uh I booked
the studio and [ __ ] and I was just like
damn bro you feel me like all my all my
partners I went to uh school with they
they the ones that got the studios now
like they're the ones they got the crazy
friends
so yeah it's cool to see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] producing [ __ ] doing all kind
of cool [ __ ] so hopefully it'll be more
[ __ ] come out the crib be feeding me
in a year to come I ain't say yours I
said the year to come too oh God